so we heard a quote from Chad Lindberg
who's also in the film and it went
something like this everyone needs to
fall on their face at some point can you
tell us how not only did you hit some
rough patches but also the gentleman in
the movie did as well and their own
careers in their house um I think what
Chad meant by that too is is you learn
from mistakes you learn from falling you
learn from failing you learn from trying
and not really getting what you want and
you also learn from getting what you
want and losing it so it's like I think
we had all aspects in and at the house
and Joaquin oh I mean you do see it in
the movie in my big break so it's almost
like without it you really almost if
everything is just great and you're
working and it's almost you're clueless
in a way and once you hit a problem I
think a lot of people either they they
just can't cope you know and so you know
it's part of it part of learning it's
like you can't every time go to an
audition you're going to get apart it's
like you know and you can't every time
you make a movie you think you're gonna
sell it you'll sell it I mean it just
it's it makes you more determined to
falling and like being really smacked in
the face because you know it just makes
you tougher you know
a lot of the film touches on addiction
issues why do you think people self
medicate so much in Hollywood is just
part of the lifestyle it's more free
people more in touch with sort of
wanting to feel things and so since i
think it's i think it's the loneliness
of the town I think it's more I think
it's the loneliness and I think it's the
it's very competitive it's a very there
is a lot of people feel you're very
vulnerable i think and then they feel
like that the drugs drinking or whatever
they are in like like to do is that
actually gives them that kind of sense
escape so it starts to kind of feel like
this is okay and it's almost like
there's a lot of tension here for
because it's there's a lot of rejection
so if you're being rejected every single
day when you go out to three times on an
audition even if you're lucky to get
these auditions it's very difficult I
think to butch yourself through as an
actor too good or casting directors to
auditions two or three times a day if
you're lucky to get that and you know
you would hear feedback like you know
your nose is too big your chin is not
this your your eyes are not the right
color you're not handsome enough or
she's not sexy enough or she doesn't
have the right accent and it just it's a
constant rejection I think people get
very traumatized by you know we just I
mean people are attacking the way you
look the way you talk it's too much for
her being you know
for a person to go through do you think
there's a way to be in this business
without numbing yourself through drugs
what do you think it's it's almost
impossible oh yeah I don't know a lot of
people do it with that I mean some
people are able to do it I don't think I
don't think I don't who I'm not even
saying that you have to do drugs a lot
of people don't do the drugs a lot of
people start doing the drugs and then
they quit and they realize that just
stupid to do you really don't you know
it's because you're taking a negative
and then you were in another negative on
top of it so it's like you're getting
rejection every day and it's very hard
here so the solution is just actually
find a way to deal with it but instead
you go do drugs on top of it you just
might as well just let go kill yourself
because you're not going to accomplish
anything from that and it's always a bad
ending so you put together a new version
of the film you call it my big break
what's then your next step are you
calling all the guys you know Chad Brad
um what they do know that I did that
then you cut was completed they were
again because we live in different
places now so I couldn't get everybody
one place to watch the movie and I
didn't think that this was going to be
the movie like oh let's have a premiere
for it was too intense
to have everybody in one place and also
to deal with this whole thing so it was
like the movies out and they watched it
all at there on time when they were able
to i don't think was seen it yet from
what I've heard you know I mean we do
talk through emails occasionally but but
yeah we didn't really watch the film
together and what do you think this film
is for um factors and filmmakers sorry
yeah int actors and filmmakers and why
do you think that this film is so
emotional to so many people I know for
us it was emotional we've we've heard
from other people that have seen it this
yeah well it's it's always even
emotional for people that are not in the
business to because I think it's any
time you have a story about being young
and having possibilities and
opportunities and then you watch a movie
and you feel people are very they have
this sadness about that they lost
something or that they had everything
because having everything especially in
this town is very it's not easy to get
and so when you sit and you're watching
you go oh I think people always relate
to when you have characters in the movie
that are going you know if I could just
go back when I had this opportunity or
if I was young enough or if I could get
another part I think that really freaks
people out and I think some people don't
see past that it's almost like I got it
once I can't get it back and I think
people really overreacted do you think
that people don't understand when big
stars have walls around them
they think that oh they've changed their
stuck up but really maybe it's more self
preservation hi i just i think for
actors to have also that wall around is
ridiculous because I mean any working
actor should realize that I understand
that like you're probably you're so
lucky to be working that it's like you
shouldn't really have any demands you
shouldn't really have any weird behavior
and insist on having this or that I
think it's just like completely and not
I don't buy that I think people that do
that they either they just create a
horrible reputation for themselves
people don't want to work with them and
it's like it's just not creative it's
not colon they just create that world
around them because they're just
irritable and no i don't think so do you
think that new things will happen with
the film are you happy with where it's
at i mean are you planning to take it to
festivals or or you have it on dystrophy
you have it on your site for sale yes
you know we stopped submitting to
festivals and all that it's just I feel
like it's done it's done it's out there
I don't fight it I realize that you know
the Internet is amazing people are just
they find stuff so you know so we we
promote online people get to know what
people like it when they see it it's
always it's just one thing about letting
people know about it's like anybody that
sees them with likes it the thing is how
are you gonna find that person and will
that cost money to advertise and if
you're gonna do it that way then you
need somebody else to pick it up and so
we didn't go in that route we're just
have her in our website and when people
search one of the actors or they look up
the movie there is always a very easy
way to like just look on the site and
either go get it from amazon from
dystrophy and watch it and i think it's
nice to just have it sit there and like
it's almost like it's always ready for
everyone for whoever is ready to see it
and you know we did the festival's for a
while and
and that's it it's just out there now
it's time to move on I guess well what
was it that was inside of you that you
couldn't let go of the film because
obviously you you had moved away but you
came back to a new piece of a great
story it's a really good story because
yeah the first guy I I thought it was a
good movie but it didn't have that the
consequences it didn't have the
rejection as much it didn't have you
know the great kind of elements of a
story where you go out it's the hero's
journey where you're like trying to go
get something and then you're completely
you get so much and then you lose
everything and you can you come back
broken and then you rebuild I mean you
can't write that so it had all these
elements and I'm like are you kidding
this is great you know so that's the
really the part that I'm really proud of
you